بهذا التصريح للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي قال فيه ان العمليات
العسكريه التي تنفذها قوته بلاده في شمال
سوريا والعراق لن تقتصر على الغارات
الجويه واضاف اردوغان ان النقاشات بشان
اشراك قوات البريه في العمليه ستجرى مشيرا
الى ان المهمه تتلخص في القضاء على
المنظمات الارهابيه وفقه تعبيره
واشار الرئيس التركي الى ان روسيا لم
تلتزم باتفاق سوتشي بشان تطهير المنطقه من
الارهابيين وانا تركيه سبق لها ولكنها لن
تصمت اذا ذلك وهو ما حدث بالفعل كما قال
واضاف اردوغان ان انا تركيه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تنضويان معا تحت مظله
حلف شمال الاطلسيه نيته لكنه واشنطن ارسلت
رغم ذلك
الاليات والاسلحه الى منطقه الارهاب في
سوريا على حد تعبيره واشاره الى انه جرى
ابلاغ الولايات المتحده امتعاض تركيا من
ارسالها اسلحه الى ارهابيين في سوريا وذلك
منذ عهد اوباما لكن الامر استمر مع
الادارات الامريكيه لاحقه
قال وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان
احد القتلى طفل والاخر مدرسه
في تركيا في ساعات ظهور اليوم ما ادى الى
مقتل مواطنين للاسف هناك طفل رضيع ومعلمته
من ضمن القتلى كما جرح سته وهم يتلقون
العلاج حاليا في المستشفيات نؤكد ان
العمليه العسكريه التي بدات بالامس وسببت
الكثير من الخسائر للمنظمه الارهابيه
ستستمر داخل تركيا وخارجها وسنعطي الجواب
المناسب وسنقوم بما يجب القيام به
هذا وقال وزير الدفاعي تركي خلاص يا كار
ان الضربات الجويه التي نفذتها القوات
التركيه على مواقع في منطقه عين العرب
كوباني شمال شرق سوريا وفي شمال العراق
نجحت في تدمير مواقع ومقر لمسلح حزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه التي وصفها بالمنظمات الارهابيه
التي تعود للارهابيين وتعقبنا ذلك عن كثب
وتم تدميره مقر تابعي للمنظمه الارهابيه
كما تم استهداف الارهابيين والمواقع التي
تخصهم فقط ومخلب القوات المسلحه التركيه
استادف الارهابيين مره اخرى ولدينا القدره
والاصرار على انقاذ بلدنا وشعبنا من بلاء
الارهاب المتسلط عليهم منذ 40 عاما ولم
نترك ابدا تقرا شهدائنا ومواطنين الابرياء
ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر محليه ان
القصه طال مواقع عسكريا لما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في تل رفعت وعين دقنه
في حلب وشمال عيسى في ريف الرقه ومناطقه
في الحسكه وعين العرب كوباني على الحدود
السوريه التركيه
في المقابل نقلت وكاله رويترز الانباء عن
متحدثين باسم ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي تشكل وحدات وحمايه الشعب
الكرديه عمود خلفقاري نقلت ان طائرات
تركيه قصفت قريتين ماهولتين بالنازحين في
شمال سوريا كما نقلت وكاله الانباء
السوريه عن مصدر عسكري مقتل عدد من الجنود
اثر الهجمات التركيه على ريف حلب والحسكه
معانا من انقره مراسله جزيره فرح الزمان
شوقي ومن اعزاز على الحدود السوريه
التركيه مراسل الجزيره عمر وراني نبدا معك
عمر حوراني
والمعلومات المتوفره حيث انت عن هذه
العمليه تركيه
نعم هذه المنطقه لم تهدا منذ بدء العمليه
فجر الاحد هو العمليه التي اطلق عليها
المخلب السيف والتي استهدفت مواقع لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه فجر الاحد
والمنطقه مشتعله منذ ذلك الحين بقصف
متبادل القوات التركيه وايضا تؤذرها همم
قوات التابعه للمعارضه تقصف مواقع تابعه
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وايضا هو سوريا
الديمقراطيه تستهدف مواقع هنا في شمال
سوريا وايضا القصف تجاوز الشمال السوري
وهذا هو منعطف خطير وكان القصف داخل
الاراضي التركيه القصف ايضا استهدف
امس محيط معبر باب السلامه وكان هناك سقوط
جرحه من بينهم اتراك وايضا كان هناك قصف
في مواقع اخرى منذ العمليه اذن والمنطقه
مشت وهذه المنطقه تشهد قصف ليس فقط من
قوات ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هذا
اليوم ايضا قوات النظام شنت قصف على محيط
طائره عزه وايضا الطائرات الروسيه قصفت
هذه المنطقه ايضا في منطقه في ريف ادلب
بالقرب من معبر باب الهوى بعده غارات اذا
هذه المنطقه كما ذكرنا تشهد قصف مكثف
ومتبادل
منذ بدا العمليه والتي استهدفت مواقع لما
تعرف بقوات سيره سوريا الديمقراطيه وراحه
ضحيه قتل همم فيها قرابه 30 همم منهم
ثمانيه عشر من قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وايضا
وكان ناحيه عن مقتل عدد من من جنود النظام
وتحدثت مصادر عن ان القتله من جنود النظام
همم قرابه اكثر من 10 جنود لقوات نظام
والقصف استهدف مواقع في ريف حلب وتركز في
رفعت وايضا كان هناك قصف في شرق الفرات في
الحسكه وفي الرقه وامتد القصف حينها ايضا
الى مناطق داخل الاراضي العراقيه
اي التباس ربما حول ما يجري وعن دور
القوات السوريه في قوات النظام السوري في
هذه همم المواجهات يعني من قصف قوات سوريا
نعم اذا قوات النظام همم تتواجد في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وايضا همم ما تقوله همم
القوات التركيه بان قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تحتمي بهذه القوات
وتعتبرها غطاء للقوات ما تعرف في همم
القوات التي تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
واثناء العمليه التي شنتها القوات التركيه
فجر الاحد قتل عدد من جنود النظام وهذا ما
اكدته قوات النظام لكن قوات النظام لم
تشارك يعني بحسب المصادر في القصف الذي
طال الاراضي التركيه انما هي قوات النظام
تقصف مواقع قوات المعارضه هنا في ريف حلب
وايضا في منطقه جبل الزاويه في في ادلب